I know you used to set up the lemonade
signs at a certain height so the drivers
would see them I'm curious what was
actually on those signs that attracted
the driver I remember taking note when
my mom would drive me I would pay
attention to other people's lemonade
stand and garage sale signs looking out
the window and I quickly at like seven
or eight knew that you couldn't read
them most of the time and then when it's
time for me to make my signs I'm not
going to make those same mistakes my
people are gonna be able to read it what
the sign would say is 10 cents as big as
you could imagine and I would use black
marker multiple times I knew how to make
it thick and big and simple and at eye
level and then I brought that skill to
the wine store before we got a computer
with a printer we used to make the signs
on the displays by hand and so when I
was at the register I would make the
signs regularly 8.99 on sale for 5.99
and I remember how different my signs
were when I first got to the liquor
store versus what my dad had they would
take a regular Sharpie and put 5.99 mine
would be like three times the size of
the sign the 5.99 was like bigger than
the previous sign itself like it was all
that